this is a drum work with bow Wagner so
in this talk I'd like to share some of
the recent thinking's that bow and i
have about whether we can formally
define a notion called informational
substitutes and compliments so we're
very familiar with substitutes and
compliments of goods but when it comes
to pieces of information do I have a
similar notion that we can make use of
and how such a definition like if we can
come up with a reasonable definition for
informational substitutes and
complements can help us understand the
strategic play of players in games so
what I'm going to do is that I'm going
to formally introduce the Beijing view
of information and the prediction
problem and and also the prediction
market problem so that's what multi ways
as to start to think about that we need
a notion of substitutes and complements
four pieces of information and then I
will talk about some of our attempts in
defining substitutes and compliments of
signals so this is largely conceptual
because i'm going to introducing our
definition okay and also i will be
discussed out just one prior definition
on this topic that were aware of and why
we don't think that helps us in this
particular purpose and after that so
certainly the substitutes and
complements of info of signals is not
justify the prediction problem so we
wanted to be general 40 decision
problems but actually it turns out to be
the case that prediction problems are
come basically a complete for the
purpose of thinking about compliments
and substitutes of information and will
apply our definition to thinking about
the equilibrium of prediction market so
the game theoretic equilibrium of get a
prediction market I'm not going to talk
about the specific technical derivation
about how we get the equilibrium without
but I just want to summarize the result
so far that we have with that respect
and I'll conclude with a few future
direct
so let me start talking about
information so when we talk about
information in decision science or
economics which often takes a patient
perspective of information so the
typical model that we think about is
that oh there is some events of interest
that a decision maker may care about and
that is the random variable E and for
example the event of interest that I'm
useless example could be the outcome of
a replication for behavioral experiment
ok and then information is represented
as signals so there again random
variables so individuals may have
different signals a B and C so there Oh
like random variables and for example a
particular signal could be represented
as the outcome of some related events to
the behavior experiments that we care
about and things we're talking about the
patient view and there is the prior
distribution so which is the drug
distribution of the possible outcome of
the event of interest and the possible
realizations of all the signals so this
is the commendation framework that we're
thinking about private information ok
and unlike the physical goose so people
have utility of value for just two
having the physical good so four pieces
of information it doesn't seems to be
sufficient for us to just to say that oh
I have thirsty of information I just
want to own information just owning a
piece of information given me utility so
in some sense just to talk about
information is not enough we need to
think about information in conjunction
with the decision making process so here
we're introducing a decision problem and
decision problem is defined by a set of
possible decisions that a decision maker
can pick from so that's a set D so for
example particular decision for this
example could be I'm going to follow the
recommendation of the original result so
assuming that the original behavior
experiments makes the recommendation
about what I should be doing I'm going
to follow that wreck
dation so that's my decision and
alternative decision could be that i'm
going to ignore that recommendation and
do whatever i want and a decision
problem typical is associated with the
decision makers utility and here the
utility function is a function of the
decision that the decision maker makes
and the realization the actual outcome
of the event of interest so with the
decision problem in mind we now can talk
about what's the value of information so
the value of information just to follow
the prior work basically can be defined
as the expected value of the utility
that the decision maker can get if
acquiring that information and also
follow the best decision given the
realization of that information so
essentially if I'm thinking about a
signal a which is a random variable and
taking expectation across all possible
realizations of that random variable and
I was thinking about the decision makers
maximization problem that is conditional
on a realization of the signal a and
because condition on this the decision
makers should have a distribution about
the outcome of the event of the interest
e and then the decision maker wants to
make a decision to maximize the expected
utility here so this is the value of
information that I'm referring to so so
far so good so that's information and
decision problem and a special case of a
decision problem relates just a very
simple prediction problem so in
prediction problem the the action space
of the decision space now becomes a
report space which is just that the
probability simplex over the possible
outcomes of the event e okay so really
we're just asking the decision maker to
report a distribution about the event E
and one particular way to reward the
decision maker or thinking about the
utility function of the decision maker
is to use a proper scoring roof
and a proper guru is a scarring function
that takes the report of the decision
maker and the actual realized the
outcome of the event E and return a real
value ok for example widely used a
proper scar andrew is the log scarring
rule so it's just a reward the
individual according to the log of the
probability reported for the outcome
that actually happened and i want to
emphasize proper here the proper here
really just means that it's incentive
compatible so a risk neutral participant
would want to choose foley report the
the belief that he has after getting the
information so for the decision problem
the value of information can be
simplified because we have the proper
scarran room so in some sense a decision
maker after having the signal
realization of a will have a conditional
distribution for the outcome of the
event and that's I'm representing SP a
so PA is a distribution of e conditional
on the realization of the signal like
big a turns out to be the lowercase a ok
and because we're using a proper scarran
rule it means that the the best action
or the best decision that the decision
maker can have is to choose value repot
this distribution so the value of
information is reduces to this film and
if we think about the inner expectation
here so this is the expectation so this
is essentially a function that only
depends on PA ok so i'm going to call
this function jpa for this this is
basically the expected scale function if
someone's choose fully revealing his
belief and i'll come back to this later
but in the scarborough literature there
is a very close relationship between
this function g and the corresponding
propers garden true so there's
essentially almost one-to-one mapping
and this
change is always a convex function that
that comes handy to us so that's a
special case of a decision problem is
the prediction problem and for using a
proper scarring rule we can essentially
ensure that a risk and neutral
participants will choose valeriy partner
believe to us so we get their
information so that's one agent case but
we also like to move from a one agent
case to a multiple agent case so
thinking about the multiple agents or
have information to contribute and how
can we get that information and that
becomes a prediction market so I'm
talking about a very specific form of a
prediction market that's Hanson's
markets go Andrew so essentially this is
a shared version of a proper scarring
rule so we're still considering the
event whether a starter is going to be
replicated or not but think about that
we start from some initial probability
distribution over the two possible
outcomes and the participants can just
come and sequentially change that
probability distribution to whatever
they think is correct so we have
different participant they're going to
report different probability
distribution and the market uses the
proper Scarn rule and we look at a
participant at time T and reported RT as
the probability distribution that
participants is going to get the scar on
route difference between his report and
the purest report so essentially what it
does is that instead of directly
rewarding the participants using a
scarran rule it rewards the improvement
that the participants make using the
scarran room so we're only route like
rewarding participant T based on how
much he improves beyond the previous
prediction so so in some sense anyone
can come to this market and changes the
current market prediction so the current
report measures the populations
collective Billy
leave to a certain degree and I just
want to mention that as I called this a
market but this is essentially a
sequential changing of market probably
changing of the probability repast but
it is indeed a market in a sense of like
in practice this type of mechanism is
often implemented as a market maker
mechanism treating contracts looks like
this so this is essentially a futures
contract it pays off one dollar if the
starter is replicated and zero dollar
otherwise and and predict correctly has
many applications and has been shown
that they make good predictions compared
with alternative method I just want to
mention some of the recent without that
we had coming from actually using
prediction market to predict the the
reproducibility of some of the
psychology start is so psychology as a
food they're aware of that many of the
experiments may not be reproducible so
it and and over the past few years more
than 200 researchers in psychology they
collaborate with Cod reproducibility
psychology project to reproduce a set of
selected starters from the top story
psychology journals so so far about a
hundred has been like tested so the
replication about the henrys started has
been completed so we basically piggyback
with this reproducibility starting and
we set a prediction market for 41
psychology starters we felt the
replication actually happened so that's
what we did and we like we're basically
like psychology researchers to
participate in this market and and use
the market to say whether the market
price successfully predict the outcome
of the replication and it turns out that
the price correctly predicted about 71
percent of the replications so compared
with the surveys that we conducted
before they participated in the market
so just as the simple average of the
survey would correctly predict you'll
about fifty eight percent of the
replication outcomes and if we use their
self-reported confidence to wait their
report that only gets about fifty
percent of the like replication results
correct the self-reported compass are
confident that seems to be very reliable
the rich merchant more accurate non-rev
available or beautiful studies yes I so
it's both so you might be curious about
like out of the faulty one psychology
start is how many are actually
replicated and so it's a little
disappointing so it's thirty-nine
percent were successfully replicated but
like yeah and a larger set of the star
day so so basically we only set up
prediction market for 41 starters but
but so far about a hundred has completed
and even in that said it's about around
forty percent that were successfully
replicated well if you you know like
yeah so Kevin's mission was I guess a
Thunderbird correctly what people biased
saying something will be relieved
it's actually not like we didn't notice
the bias between this two so from our
data we didn't notice that Marcus
generated press right what does it mean
leading right exactly so so if we
interpret the price as the probabilities
so what the press suggests is that the
market should correctly predict about
ninety six percent of the star days so
if you really interpret the price as the
probabilities it's a number bigger than
point five yeah so so 71 percent is like
if I'm taking that the price is higher
than point five as just to predicting
that direction that's seventy-five
percent and if we take the price to be
sixty percent like if the price like
ants s is sixty percent we know that
with sixty percent of chances by doing
that that's going to give us the correct
prediction and if we interpret that as
like the market price as a probabilistic
prediction then roughly what the market
suggest is that we should be able to use
the market to predict about sixty-nine
percent of the outcome of the
replication tangent so it seems as you
know it's also there in the strictness
of the definition of replicability how
well that replicate yeah exactly so so
basically we define that like a because
first it's a direction and second is
like with the right like p value so
essentially like strong enough and
that's that's also consistent with what
the reproducibility project is using as
was considered as replic replicate it
alright so I hope that like this means
that there's some potential interesting
applications for prediction market and
it seems to be a list of working to a
certain degree but what's puzzling to us
is that it just seems to be working but
we don't really understand very well
about how information is being reviewed
in the market and being aggregated in
the market so especially when
considering that the participants are
strategic so when using a market garden
group because the markets going to rule
uses a proper scoring rule if a
participants only participate once we
know that it's the best interest of
other participants to choose Valley
review his belief but think it's a
market a participant can participate
modern ones and can come back later on
so there's this strategic concern about
how are they going to decide when and
how much to review their information
okay and there are some work about this
trying to understand the game theoretic
equilibrium of a prediction market so i
just want to mention that so early on in
the previous session so it has a
discussion about that game theory is not
very useful for understanding the
behavior of financial market and here a
prediction market is essentially a
futures market so argue about it is
slightly either than a stock market
because it's a futures market the
outcome will eventually be revealed at
the end and second because of the
mechanism that were using so it's
essentially a one-sided mechanism
everyone's treating with the mechanism
and hopefully that makes starting the
prediction market relatively easy Singh
for understanding the strategic behavior
so so the typical model for starting
this problem is just a model the market
as a Beijing game so essentially we have
oh the same information structure so
common prior signals and event of
interest and your dish into that and the
typical assumption is that there is a
fixed outer participation so arguably
this is a very strong assumption but so
far like it's unclear how we can relax
this assumption and still contracta
bility okay and in the motor typically
either assume a finite number of runs Oh
infinite number of grams okay so so what
we know so far with the model so there
are some very interesting progress has
been made with respect to the
information aggregation in prediction
market in particular my class Travis key
essentially characterize a condition
called separuh bility condition so it's
a condition about the Securities payoff
and
underlying information structure and if
that condition is satisfied he shows
that essentially Oh information is fully
aggregated in the limit by singing in
the limit it means that as time
approaches to infinity so if we're
considering the perfect base in
equilibrium for any market scarring rule
mechanism so in the limit information is
fully aggregated so that's that's pretty
nice that's a very strong result
essentially saying that at least at the
end information is fully aggregated if
there is a perfect base in equilibrium
and a follow-up work by Chris era and
collaborators essentially extends the
setting to consider risk-averse
participants so without specific
emphasizing like in my talk other work
like uses risk neutral participants and
this is probably the only works that
considers the risk averse participants
so this set of readouts sounds good at
least it gives us some hope that
information is eventually aggregated in
a prediction market or can be aggregated
in your prediction market but it doesn't
say much about when the information is
aggregated so the limit can be very long
and the ephah if the information is not
revealed early enough a market is not
necessarily very helpful so there's some
work that we have been doing trying to
understand the structure of the
equilibrium so once the early work that
we show is that for the logarithmic
markets Garden Room so a very very
specific markets garden route using the
logarithmic proper scoring rule and if
the signals of all the participants are
conditionally independent the meaning
that condition on the two outcome of the
event the signals of the participants
independent then the Omni equilibrium in
a prediction market using LMS are is the
rush equilibria so what does the old
Russia caliber means the roughly
speaking so I'm not very precise here
but roughly speaking it means that
everyone will try to choose fully review
their information
at the first round of the participation
essentially if there is a outer of
participation than at their first round
of participation they will try to review
all their information and choose Foley
so arguably this is the really nice
equilibrium that we would like to say if
we're interested in thinking about using
prediction markets to elicit an
aggregate information so i will call
this the good equilibrium okay and so
Demetri and semi shows that oh actually
when the signals are independent so this
is unconditionally independent then in
the same mechanism we cannot have the
o.r a chic whatever so the nice
equilibrium cannot be possible you
achieved okay and with alleys and digium
so just a couple of years ago we show
that with independent signals and in the
same logarithmic marcus guru mechanism
actually the only type of equilibrium is
that ever participants would try to
delay the the revealing of their
information so that's what we call the
odelay equilibrium essentially they want
to wait until the last round of
participation intuition for what is
independent signals I mean I can
understand what's condition additional
independent yeah so that's a very good
question so conditional independent is
probably the one that like a with a loud
and independent signals I actually don't
have like a very good example so the tie
examples that I have is a supposing that
both of us each help serve the outcome
of a coin flip whether its head or tail
and the event that we're predicting is
whether like both cars come up with has
so clearly our information is related to
that outcome but unconditional on that
outcome we have independent information
amount like someone more like realistic
example will be thinking about voting if
you think that we vote independently and
we're trying to predict whether a
candidate is going to get the majority
vote that can be roughly modeled as like
independent signal
but I wouldn't strongly argued for that
yeah okay so so basically these are all
we know about the structure of the
equilibrium in prediction market and we
actually at this pine have pretty good
intuitions about why this happens so why
was conditional independence signals we
have the overall equilibrium and why was
independent signals we have the odelay
equilibrium and I'm sure that the
intuition makes sense to you too so in
some sense with conditional independence
signals the sickness of the participants
roughly can be considered as substitute
meaning that like if your signal and my
signal substitutes then I want to review
my signal and profit from that first
because after I reveal my signal your
signal is not going to be that valuable
and for the independent signals we have
the intuition that oh actually their
signals are compliments meaning that oh
I want to wait for you to review your
signal first because combining your
signal with mine I have a higher value
okay so that's the intuitions but we
struggled a lot about trying to
formalize that so we really couldn't
find a mathematical formulation for us
to be able to farm only say that Oh in
this case the signals are substitutes
and in this case the signals are
compliments so that really motivates us
to just to think about substitutes and
compliments for pieces of information in
general so for the physical goods so
substitutes and compliments are well
defined so for example cavinti are
substitutes and coffee and cake are
probably compliments and the definition
of substitutes and complements actually
a very useful so there is strong
connection between substitutes and
existence of equilibrium in markets for
goods and also in the matching market so
essentially for the physical girls it
seems to be that the definition of
substitutes and complements is crucial
of a lot of understanding of the market
behavior so we asked ourselves can we
define informational substitutes and
complements that have similar impact so
alyssa help us understand the
equilibrium in prediction market but
hopefully more broadly applicable to
other domains in general so so that's a
long motivation now let me start to talk
about how we can define substitutes and
compliments for signals okay so the only
prior definition we're aware of was by
buggers at all so they define so they
had the first of all my definition of
substitutes and complements of signals
and I just want to remind you that the
value of the information is essentially
the expected value of the the best as
the expected value of the
decision-makers utility when taking the
best action condition along the realized
signal so far bacilos definition is a
direct analogy of the substitutes and
compliments for physical goals so
essentially what it says is that two
signals and be a substitute if for every
decision problem so the sum of the value
of signal a and value of Sigma B is
greater than equal to the value of
having both a and B so this notation
means the drawing of the signals a and B
essentially means that we have both
signal a and B and plus the value of
having no signals and not seeing any of
the signal a and B so this is a direct
analogy of the compliments and
substitutes of goods okay so this sounds
very appealing because it does capture
some of the signals and and what would
consider as substitution and compliments
so for example if the events that we're
considering and the two signals the
three random variables at the same so
clearly were you know situation that
signals the substitute so any decision
problems
involves this event e 1 is going to have
signals a1 and b1 to be substitute okay
alternatively firs think about a
different example if the event here is
the XL relationship between the two
signals and clearly we're in the case
this two signals a compliment but we
also find this definition to be very
difficult to work with but in the sense
of it doesn't depends on the decision
problem so I highlighted here this is a
definition for every decision problem so
it requires that two signals a and B has
to satisfy this inequality for every
possible decision problem that you can
imagine and and sometimes signals can be
substitutes for one decision problem and
complement for another decision problem
for example if you think about two
pieces of signals one is the price for
attacks dog ate the other is the price
for text up be and if my decision
problem is whether I want to invest in a
text stock phone or index fund then
these two signals probably a substitute
but if my decision is which one of these
two stocks I want to invest in this two
signals of property compliments so I
need to know both of them so in some
sense we really want the definition to
depend on the decision problem so that
we can see something specific justify
that decision problem rather than just a
concluding that oh it doesn't satisfy
this definition and we don't know
whether it's substitutes or compliments
and the second potential problem that we
encounter with this definition is that
this definition doesn't depends on the
internal structure of the signals if you
think about that oh I'm just a combining
this two events into a drawing to even
be here and I'm a combining this two
signals into a drunk signal a here and
similarly John signal be here so if
you're thinking about like
EA and be so some of its components are
substitute but the other part of their
components a compliment and the
definition of this doesn't consider the
internal structure of the signals won't
capture anything represented here so we
start by allowing the definition of
substitutes and complements to depend on
the decision problem and also depends on
the internal structure of signals and in
order for us to make a definition like
that we need to place a structure on the
signals so the structure that we are
considering is the Blackwell partial
artery so this is a Blackwell
informativeness criteria what it
basically says is that the signal a
prime is less informative than the
signal ay if ay prime is a gabbling of a
so gabbling of a can be thought as like
adding nice to a oh there exists a
stochastic mapping from a to a prime and
just like any randomized strategy given
a is the babbling of a so essentially
we're enforcing a partial uttering of
informative news of signals and we're
going to make use of this to define
substitutes of signals okay so so here
is our definition so the power wise
substitutes so I'm only going to talk
about the substitutes because the
compliments case is just to change in
the direction of the inequality so we're
saying that signals a and B as
substitutes so here we r specifically
define that for a decision problem and
for prior p so essentially for
information structure and so there are
substitutes if for all the signals
that's less informative than a we have
this in ecology satisfied let me try to
explain what this equality means the
singing quality essentially saying that
oh the left hand side is the marginal
value of having be having signal be in
addition to already having signal any
prime the right hand side is the
marginal value of having signal be in
addition to all right
having the signal a so the in ecology
says that if a prime is less informative
than a then a and be a substitute if the
marginal value of B given a prime is
greater than the marginal value of B
given a 0 in other words knowing more
about a reduces the value of B so so
essentially captures the decreasing
marginal value of signals okay and the
same master hold like like something
analogous leemaster hold 40 like B prime
that's less informative than being and
complements basically just reverse the
direction of the ontology here okay so
so that's our definition so we're
defining that for particular decision
problem and we're taking into
consideration of the internal structure
of the signal so this looks like a
stronger definition potentially and
there might be some some a and B that
are neither substitutes no compliment it
definitely can be so I I don't know
whether this is stronger than the
previous one because this is like
decision problem specific and the
previous one must satisfy 40 decision
problem so in general eyes do you think
that the previous one would like is
probably likely to be stronger than this
one because this one like we can define
things specific to the decision problem
isn't the first one just quantify is
this is this condition just quantified
overall decision problems no so this is
actually a particular decision problem
so because we have the utility function
here right but is it the first one just
this has to hold the same condition has
to hold for every decision problem so
now this is a so it has to hold forever
decision problem but it has a difference
is that it only considered the extreme
case of a and B so here we have the
condition of saying that it has to be
from 0 a prime that's less informative
that I essentially what is saying here
is that oh if n be a substitute then any
part of a and B has to also be
substitute
difference between so that activity and
sub modular exactly it does has a
connection with some under larity
overset functions okay how much time do
I have it is great um ok so this easily
generates two substitutes of a set of
signals because if you want to consider
like any game that has more than two
players we need to be able to talk about
substitutes for a set of signals and
what it says is that a set of signal a
set of n signal substitute if we're
considering like assuming any pair of a
energy AJ belong to the set and
revealing any combination of other
signals see and consider the combined
signal anz and the combined tsyganov
AGNC there's to paralyze substitutes
what is saying is that oh so suppose
that I've already learned some of the
other signals now I'm adding my own
signal to whatever ready are learned and
i'm adding your signal to work that's
already learned and this two new signals
are still substitute ok so so that's our
definition so hopefully sounds sensible
to you I don't have time to really
justify that but I just want to make i
will make a few comments later on about
it so what's interesting is that our
definition is for any decision problem
but we kind of have a revelation
principle type of result basically
saying that prediction problems are
complete for the purpose of thinking
about informational substitutes and
compliments so essentially what it says
is that for any decision problem you so
they're actually exists a proper scary
rule as such that for all the prayers p
& o possible signals the value of the
signal in your original decision problem
is the value of the signal in my new
decision problem with the scarring rule
and this is actually very easy to prove
by
basically saying that assuming that
given my signal I have a distribution
are for the event E and then this t star
is my optimal decision with that
distribution and I just set this to be
my scarring rule and it's easy to prove
that this is a proper scarring rule so
what it says is that so it without loss
of generality to just a focusing on
prediction problem if we're considering
the informational substitutes and
compliments and by focusing on just a
prediction problem with scoring rules
the value of any signal as I've shown
before is the expected value of a G
function of a prediction essentially and
this G function is a convex function and
I think i'm going to skip this figure
but what i want to say that so there's a
very tight connection between convex
function and proper scarring rules and
by reducing all the problems all the
decision problems to prediction problem
it will allow us to make use of our
understanding of the convexity of the
expected scale function and we actually
have other definitions that's equivalent
to what i have shown you about
substitutes and compliments of
information and that give us a lever of
true things so i miss the connection
between the revelation principle and the
structure of signals the structure of
the signal
no so this basically saying that for any
decision problem i have a corresponding
prediction problem that is going to
preserve the same substitutes and
complements property for all the signals
so so I'm not this is a generic
statement so this is a generic statement
basically for any set of signal any
information structure you are
considering so if you give me a decision
problem I can find a corresponding
prediction problem and just to start
eight that prediction problem ok I think
I have maybe five minutes let me just
quickly tell you like with this
definition of substitutes and
compliments of information what we can
say about like game theoretic
equilibrium of prediction markets so so
basically what it says is that if
signals are strict to substitute then
ever patient Nash equilibrium is the old
rash equilibrium so we're considering
extensive from game so the right
solution concept probably something like
perfect vision equilibrium but we're
staining this validation Nash
equilibrium because a perfect Beijing
equilibrium is a refinement of the beige
Nash equilibriums of this statements
actually stronger and this is in some
sense also tied meaning that like if
signals are not substitute then there
exists a trading outer wear some
participants would want to initially
withhold information so the won't
actually review their information
immediately and similar results host for
compliments so if signals the strict
complements the every patient Nash
equilibrium is the old delay equilibrium
everyone try to wait until their last
around participation to participate in
the game and this is also tied in the
sense of like if signals and now
compliments then there exist they're
treating outerwear some participant
initially review some information so so
what does it mean so we're also
interested in understanding the signal
classes so we know that from the early
readout for the logarithmic markets car
in rule when signals the conditioner
independent we have the a rash
equilibrium and when the signals
independent we have the odelay
equilibrium and the result I just to
show you our for any market scoring
rules so not specific ones so
essentially just a father just a using
the definition of substitutes and
compliments so the signal classes we
actually can characterize that so the
independent signals are complements in
any decision problem where J so G is
associated with the corresponding
scarring rule has the jointly convex
bragman divergence so Jessica convex
function so it has a pregnant divergence
well-defined if this bregman divergence
is strongly convex in both argument than
four independent signals so there are
compliments ok so this include the
logarithmic scale rules and quadratics
Carl rules so the quadratic scary part
was a known before and so conditional
independence signals were hoping that
maybe it also works for other scoring
rules but it turns out that there there
substitutes for locks garen rules but
they're not necessarily substitutes
evenfall quadratics garen rules so it's
too wide open question about like how
can we characterize the signal classes
yeah man it's unlikely racial property
more likely ratio
okay we'll check about that thank you I
just want to make a few other comments
so substitutes and compliments of
signals connect to as you probably
expected submodule and super model is
set functions so over lattices of
signals but the lattice needs to be
carefully defined okay so this also
allow us to have some algorithm career
dolls for some combine an aerial signal
selection problem because we can
leverage results from the submodular set
function okay and our definition also
have a nice information theoretic
interpretation that I didn't have time
to talk about it I just want to mention
of your ongoing and future directions so
what makes us very excited about this
definition is now when we think about
the good and bad equilibrium in
prediction market we really want to
achieve the good equilibrium so it opens
has the question of if we know the
signal structure of the participants can
we design a scoring function such that
with that scoring function the set of
signals becomes the substitute and that
way we essentially can make sure that
the good equilibrium happens so we're
fairly confident that this can be done
although i don't have the like oh the
details yet and the other open questions
are the characterizing signal classes
together with the decision problems so
trying to understand when our signal
substitutes for what classes of the
decision problems and when are the
compliments and we're also wondering
whether there's any connection mouth and
rooster the similarity like at the
definition level between substitutes and
complements of goose and substitutes and
complements of signals so sex a lot
what good question and then we provide
some intuition why because conditionally
and then signals can be substitutes
because my intention would be that they
would always be complementing each other
and what is that intuition something I
have an independence it more and you
have some and potentially my signal
doesn't tell anything about your signal
so knowing your signal should always
help me enforcer it's conditional on the
true state of the world conditional on
the outcome of the event so our
information is independent in some sense
if I'm knowing your information it gives
me more information about the underlying
outcome of the event so I think that's I
don't know whether that's precise but
that's kind of the intuition of like
essentially knowing your information
give me a little more information about
the underlying true state of the world
and things we're making prediction about
that and that piece of information or
kind of the common information the
mutual information
okay that's good